foreign
some of the questions underlying today's
uh core idea and the first one is the
question of is there an objective truth
in the first place anyway or is it a
question of perspective and that will
then underline I think some of the
questions of Freedom that we have been
discussing that we'll move on to in a
moment so Tommy can I start with you is
there in fact an objective truth nice
small question for a Friday afternoon I
mean if you mean an objective truth
that's Eternal that we have knowledge of
uh I would say even if it did exist we
don't have the perspective or the
perception of what it could be so we can
have tentative truths like things that
we posit as being probabilistically true
or things that tend not to change shape
as easily as falsehoods but though
that's the best that we can get to I
think that part of the issue is this
claim to objective truth the idea that
we've had an absolute that only certain
people can Intuit or certain people
could have access to is largely the
problem both of our narrow disciplines
our eurocentric education our
misunderstanding of the construction of
civilization itself
um ultimately the erroneous Pursuits
that we engage that lead us to replace
say issues of finding truth with our
most convenient political ideology of
the day
um would you not to steal words from
Kathleen's Mountain I will in fact make
sure that she gets to ask this question
in her own terms in just 30 seconds but
in terms of objective truth is this
something that's particularly a problem
with the social sciences and Humanities
or is it something that we should be
looking to all forms of knowledge all
kinds of epistemic conversation well I
think I think when you get to some of
the hard Sciences there's an
understanding that scientific
methodology leads to probabilistic
truths things that can be in return with
new findings uh the problem in
Humanities largely you know this is kind
as well right in in the idea that we're
constructing and trying to pursue
knowledge often we take shortcuts
because the moralization of what we take
to be the right are the good so plants
are a mythological rigor so I can study
race I equal my idea before I even look
at the society is we should include and
integrate everyone well is that the best
thing to solve racial or ethnic
differences in a given Society you know
that's not always the case so objective
truth becomes a very moralistic and
politically infused idea given the lack
of rigorous testing and verifiability of
the humanities and social sciences which
is something I don't think the hard
science is necessarily suffer wrong
because there's a kind of falsifiability
in their theories
[Applause]
and Kathleen I know you're going to be
speaking later on in fact about your
book Material Girls but of course part
of the controversy you're involved in at
Sussex was the question of what can and
cannot be debated as objective truth in
that case particularly in the case of
biology
yeah I mean the questions posed I think
misleadingly it's an opposition there is
truth it's objective and perspectable I
mean it's both uh you're never going to
get you know very very
uh perspective neutral objectivity
because we are human beings with uh
differing perceptual faculties however
there are clearly some very stupid and
wrong answers we can definitely
eliminate quite a lot of things and uh
even where you admit that the truth is
perspectival it's not up to me you know
it's not it's not totally arbitrary or
keyed into individuals it's shared
perspectives derived through cultural
social means so you can still find out
about those and you can try and make
inferences about what contribution the
social has and what contribution the
natural has and where the universities
often have gone wrong in Humanities is
taking away the natural and thinking
that everything's up for social kind of
construction and that they get to
construct it because of course it's not
a coincidence academics end up in charge
of social construction if there's no
such thing as reality it puts them at
the center of the universe which is a
really powerful position for them to be
or they so they think so they just get
to make uploads of [ __ ] and uh so we
need to go back to a more constrained
and reasonable social constructivism
which recognizes that there are bits of
the world that we can do nothing about
and then think about our own our
perspectives interact with it
um Aaron the 18th century philosopher
label Von Ranka was unfortunately not
available for the debate today his agent
wasn't returning calls but he did put
forward the idea that you could look at
history as something vs
things as they really were is that
actually the kind of objective reality
in terms of our interpretation of the
past and present that we could really
aspire to or is that just a pipe dream
wow German historiography I didn't think
I'd be uh wow um we aim to please yeah
it's what the kids want yeah that's what
they talk about on Tick Tock
um
I I I
um you know I'm a Marxist so I obviously
I I generally look at Social existence
as you know the whole quote of man is
the social fact
um and I think the good thing with the
scientific method is that it gives us a
certain humility like you say about
falsifiable data and so on and and that
quote unquote factors is contingent
until you know further exploration and
new studies and and we actually learn
even more and I do think there's a
certain conceit at the heart of the
humanity sometimes which doesn't have
that humility for quite obvious reasons
because like you say it's not often
testing falsifiable
um propositions in terms of history I
mean could you re-re formulate that so
is there a truth content to the
historical process well actually could I
do that by just taking something you've
just said I mean as a Marxist you might
prefer Hegel to uh we should really
spend the entire session talking about
18th century and 19th century philosophy
that is what the audience won but when
you said man is a social fact you know
again you could immediately pick back
and say well now we might say the human
is a social fact by changing that
phrasing do what do we change about the
objective reality of the social fact you
want to posit it's a very good question
that's a very good question that should
mean that man is as a social humans or a
social being
um we are social beings and that the
forms of existence within which we we
find ourselves is is contingent to a
certain extent on
what he would call the economic base now
I don't agree with that entirely and I
think Stuart brand comes up with a much
more powerful idea called pacelayers and
this is how the historical process works
at the bottom of the pace layer is
nature very powerful there if that goes
wrong the rest of it collapses it could
be an extinction level event it could be
a pandemic but then above the the nature
Pace layer you have culture which is
clearly contingent it's changing and
it's flexible all the time and above
that you know you've got Commerce you've
got governance of course these change
all the time too and what they think is
right and right at the top you have
fashion which is incredibly transient
and Whimsical and changes by virtue of
what it is constantly and so for me
um I I would say that clearly the the
observing the entirety of human
existence
um I think again gives you a certain
humility around yeah humans as a social
fact we've been around there were humans
anatomically identical to us they were
around 300 000 years ago identical to us
then something very strange happens I
mean some people have revisionist views
on this but let's just stick to the
science so we're not meant to say that
but let's stick to the Science 12 000
years ago we get the Neolithic
Revolution Agriculture and off the back
of Agriculture writing cities
mathematics astronomy and now we're here
2022 electric vehicles mobile phones the
internet so so clearly I I am very
hesitant for people to categorize and
box what it is to be human when clearly
we've changed so dramatically that's the
essence of our Humanity Catherine yeah I
mean it just to respond to that it's one
thing to say that we've changed and
clearly we have but I think for me the
the move from man to human
um was a bit of a mistake because it
put plugged Us in as different from all
everything else that lives on the planet
like we are not like other animals and
of course we are all animals and we are
you know related to chimps and bonobos
and we have a lot of material facts
about us that um especially in the
enlightenment liberal tradition which
goes along with sort of freak Freedom as
The Guiding metaphor
we want to be free of all that we don't
want to be animals we want to be like in
charge of our own Destinies and not
determined by our genes or our hormones
or whatever and that that narrative in
the 21st century is Going Bonkers and
now people want to be free of their own
bodies and they want to be you know
transhumanism all that stuff so I
there's nothing wrong with you know if
it's just a quick transition from you
know whatever prehistoric to
Agricultural Revolution fine but let's
not remember forget that we are still
animals Tommy
yeah I mean these are very difficult
questions right because
the very notion that we have of the
human that appeals to biology right to
the to the dichotomy that's being
created between man or human and animal
these are products of certain kinds of
World Views these are very recent
Notions that didn't exist in indigenous
African even ethnological Societies in
Europe in the 19th century so if we're
trying to get back to an understanding
of what the human is or the way the
human moves through history the question
becomes what history and whose history
and and that that idea that there's
somehow a universal grounding by which
we could talk about the evolution and
development of the human
um it's something that I think underlies
some of the nation social
constructionism today because we're
we're not looking at an interpreter
framework like think about Houston
Chamberlain for instance right you're
you're not dealing briefly who Houston
Channel okay so Chamberlain's uh a
British guy that's a germapho that uh
germaphile that love Nazism but one of
the interesting things about him was
that he argued that the Teutonic people
were the ones that were destined to rule
the world where as you know British
Anglo-Saxon people thought they were the
ones that were gonna rule the world and
bring reason the reason that's
interesting though is because it gives
you this very same question about the
failures or crises of the 20th century
which group of people that Define
themselves as the original and the most
insightful having access to the truth
get to decide the fate of the world and
what I fear happens in the western
metaphysical tradition is there are
multiple claims usually at the racial
where people Define what humanity is to
the exclusion of other groups of people
so that's a really good place to get to
the second part of our discussion which
gets right to the present day and
present day issues now to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV